- [Announcer] this program is presented
by University of California Television.
Like what you learned?
Visit our website or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest UCTV programs.
(light music)
- Welcome to a Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Daniel B. Rodriguez
who is dean and Harold
Washington professor
at Northwestern Law School.
Dean Rodriguez recently completed his term
as the 2014 president of
the Association of American Law Schools.
Dean Rodriguez is the 2015
Jefferson Lecturer at Berkeley.
Dan, welcome to Berkeley.
- Glad to be here.
- [Harry] Where were you born and raised?
- I was born about 500
miles south of here.
Long Beach, California.
A little bit south of Los Angeles.
- And, looking back, how do
you think your parents shaped
your thinking about the world?
- That's interesting.
I grew up in lower to middle class family
and not a particularly academic family.
Nonetheless, they encouraged me
in my own academic pursuits.
And, if I had to summarize it,
I would say that they taught
me the value of hard work
and persistence and so again,
even though academic life
was remote from their own experience,
they were very proud
of me and encouraged me
to really work hard and to aspire.
- And when did the idea of
possibly pursuing the law...
Did it germinate with the
family or did that come later?
- It came much later.
My own experience was a little unusual.
I came out of high school
with no particular aspirations
to go to college, quite frankly,
and began in community
college in Long Beach.
And went from there to
California State University at Long Beach.
And, for basically 4/5 of
my time at Long Beach State,
I worked full-time and
went to school at night.
So I was happy being
there and worked hard,
but didn't have a particular
aspiration for graduate school,
much less law school.
If I had to source it, I would say
it was fairly late in my
time at Long Beach State
where the idea was planted
to go to law school.
I really enjoyed studying the subjects
political science, economics.
And I thought law school
would be a great aspiration,
but it was a bit of a lark, quite frankly,
to apply to law school at the time.
- And, going back to
your earlier education,
did you have mentors that
really pushed you along
with the importance of education
in the way your parents had?
- Yes, I had a number of
mentors at Long Beach State.
Now, again, I wouldn't
diminish them by saying
that they didn't contribute a lot
to my development of my ideas.
I wouldn't look back and say,
"Oh, that professor or this professor
really gave me a way of shaping
my looking at the world."
But, on the other hand,
they encouraged me greatly
to aspire to go to get
additional education.
And so it was really the
confidence that I built
from my time at Long Beach State
that gave me the confidence that
I knew that I could really thrive
in a graduate school,
law school environment.
- [Harry] And where did
you go to law school?
- I went to law school
at Harvard Law School.
- And, at Harvard, what attracted you
in the subfields of law?
- Well, so, I loved law school, I confess,
and particularly my first year,
which, in law school,
is a three year program
is really your core year.
Subjects that I studied
and we studied at Harvard
were very much like the
subjects that law students
would study 100 years ago.
It was really a core knowledge.
So my first year was really
devoted to developing,
really, a background
and a base of knowledge
and way of thinking.
What we sometimes call
thinking like a lawyer.
It was really only when I got near the end
of my law school career
and was taking more elective subjects
and working with some
terrific faculty members that
I really started to develop
and nurture my interest in public law.
Which, in a nutshell, is
really about the relationship
between law and the government.
About governance in the United States.
And so the courses that I took,
papers that I was doing,
my work on the Law Review
really kind of gelled to
develop my intellectual
and academic interest in law.
- Your interests came to be defined
and the research you later
pursued sort of emphasized
the dynamic of federalism on the one hand,
the relationship of local
government and state government,
but also the way it's embedded
in the politics of the time.
- Well, you put it very well and
would that I had such a clearly defined
research agenda in law school.
I certainly didn't.
But certainly...
And that came later.
But certainly that describes very well
what I was mostly taken with
when I was in law school.
It interested me.
So I did what is essentially
my master's thesis.
What they call the third year paper.
On federalism in the Republican tradition.
And so, some of the themes
that you just mentioned.
And really about the relationship
among structures of government
and national, state, and local governments
and just really how we govern
ourselves in a free society
really, again, grew out of
my intellectual interest.
When I look back, by the way,
on what I wrote in law school,
it's remarkably callow
and naive, I have to say.
But, really, the germs of what
became my sort of academic projects
when I joined the faculty here.
- And this must be a fertile time
for that kind of research,
because the balance
seems to be tipping away
from the central government
and back to the states.
Is that a fair assessment?
- It's an absolutely fair assessment.
When I was coming out of law school
and, really, was beginning
my academic career,
on the one hand, it was
then a fertile time,
because many of these issues, of course,
were very prominent in American politics.
On the other hand, they
weren't particularly
fertile in American law.
To make a long story short,
the United States Supreme Court
had mostly absented themselves,
really, ever since the New Deal,
from major disputes
involving the relationship
between the state and
national governments.
You could count on one hand
the number of blockbuster
Supreme Court decisions
on that topic.
And, moreover, local government law,
while very important to a handful
of distinguished political scientists,
including some at this
wonderful university,
was not something that was
high on the priority list
of academics.
In fact, if I could tell
you just a short story,
when I came to the dean of this law school
when I was a pre-tenured faculty member,
I said I really wanted to teach a course
in state and local government law.
And he sort of looked at me and said,
"You know, we don't do that
sort of thing here at Berkeley.
We're a national law school.
And you might want to leave that
until after you get tenure."
That was sort of the
status of that subject
in American law schools when
I began my academic career.
- And what drew you to the subject?
Was it anything in your background?
Or was it just you saw
it as a fallow field?
- You know, it was really the latter.
As I started to really bear down
on very important issues of governance,
read the literature,
and look at what was going on in the world
in which I was living.
Particularly in a place like California.
In Northern California.
I always came back to the phenomenon of
of state and local governments.
And particularly how
important and critical
were issues of governance
at the local level.
There was, as you probably recall,
quite a lot of conversation about
regionalism and regional governance.
Particularly in this part of the world
where you have so many counties
sort of engaged and colliding in issues.
There were so many
fertile topics of study.
But, at the same time, not
that many law professors.
Not that many public law scholars
who are really, really looking closely at
issues of state governance
and local governance.
There was a sense that there's
not a lot in it for them.
And none of us really
wanted to be specialists
in, say, California law
or Massachusetts law.
So, I saw this area as an
area of enormous interest
and quite a lot of fertile topics.
- And, since you were in law school,
the time has come for that agenda,
really, in a very pronounced way.
As we see, for example, with Obamacare
where all the arguments are about
the relationship to the state,
for example with the
regard to the exchanges,
and whether there should
be national exchanges
if there are no state exchanges.
- Well, there's no question about that.
I mentioned, a moment ago,
that it wasn't, when I
began my academic career,
an extremely active time
in the adjudication and the
judicial process in federalism.
Well, that changed quite a bit.
It really changed, in large part,
due to the innovations of the
so-called Rehnquist court.
So, there was, over the
past, really, two decades,
a greater amount of attention
on the part of the federal courts,
particularly the Supreme Court,
on issues of federalism.
At the same time...
And you mentioned Obamacare.
The last three or four
presidential administrations
have brought a number of just
fascinating, interesting,
novel experiments with
regard to the relationship
among the state and federal government.
But also with regard to the relationship
between Congress and the presidency.
So you have two fascinating
sort of clusters of activities colliding.
The greater innovation
and work done in the
political branches, in
the political process.
But also a greater amount of attention
on the part of the Supreme Court
in these particular issues.
- Did your background in
political science or whatever,
a continuing interest you have in politics
inform your legal research?
- You know, the answer is yes.
But in a little incongruous way.
So, again, my own experience in college
is how I've described it.
My experience in law school
is as a hard-working law student,
but it really began when
I began my academic career
here at Berkeley.
And I had the wonderful opportunity
to learn from and study
with a number of colleagues.
Both within the law
school here at Boalt Hall,
but also a little more indirectly
with some terrific political scientists.
The role, just for example,
of the Institute of Governmental
Studies here at Berkeley
was very important on me.
Unlike law professors these days
who tend to come to law teaching careers
with another advanced degree.
That's, by far, the most
common professional.
I didn't.
So, I came here, in some sense,
not being excessively humble,
with no particular business
being a tenure-track faculty member.
I didn't have another graduate degree.
So much of my education was,
as they say, on-the-job training.
So my first few years here at Berkeley
really developed a very strong interest in
and I think a lot of training
in political science,
some amount of political
theory, economics.
That really helped
burnish my academic skills
- And so, in a way, the challenges
you confronted as an individual
are comparable to the
challenges you confront
as a law school dean in
rethinking law school curriculum.
- You know, I hadn't really
thought about it that way,
but I find that quite insightful.
You know, I wouldn't have
thought about that at the time
as I began my administrative career,
but, yes, in short, I think I brought
both my training and my perspectives
as an on-the-job trainer in these
to my administrative career.
- I like to ask my guests about
the skills and temperament
that are part of the profession or career
that you've chosen.
And I know that that's changing,
but let's talk about the
time when you were a student
and then we'll move to how
that might be changing.
So, what are the skills that,
in your day, were seen as
important for a law student?
- Well, certainly, an
enormous amount of energy
and attention to the study
and into that process.
My experience at Harvard,
and I have no reason to
believe it would be different
at the other great American law schools,
was not exactly the Paper
Chase, if you recall that,
but it was not long after that.
There was a hierarchy and
there was an expectation
that we were there to
study and learn the law
through the Socratic method
and through, really, old techniques.
Rigor was very important.
We felt like we knew a lot
from our undergraduate careers
and we were all very smart
and did well on tests.
But the expectations that the faculty
had for us as law
students in terms of rigor
and explaining our arguments and analyzing
was really absolutely critical.
For some of us, not so much
myself, but some of us,
we came into law school
with an enormous
experience in that regard.
For others, we developed that
while we were in law school.
So I would say to have a
sense of just rigor and care,
not only in the study, but in expression.
We like to say, in the
practice of American law,
that the importance, particularly
in the United States,
of written communication
is absolutely critical.
You know, we watch on television
the Perry Masons or the Law and Orders
or somebody arguing for the Supreme Court
and you get the sense that we're all
a bunch of junior Daniel Websters.
But the reality is most...
The bottom line is most
of the practice of law
and most of the process of advocacy
comes through written expression.
So the ability to develop the skills
to express yourself in written form
is absolutely critical for a law student.
- What about temperament?
- This might be a somewhat
surprising answer,
but I think humility is a big part of it.
I think, as the old saying goes,
knowing what you don't know.
Which, in the study of law
and the practice of law,
is a good deal, to put it mildly.
So having the temperament
in which you have
the kind of modesty or humility.
I'll give you an example.
One of our distinguished
graduates of the law school
that I'm the dean of
is a man who's argued
more Supreme Court cases
than any living lawyer, nearly 80.
And so, I asked him one time,
"There's nothing you don't know.
You've practiced before the
Supreme Court nearly 80 times.
You must be so used to it."
And the answer he gave
was really surprising.
He says, "I have humility
every single time.
Not fear.
But humility in terms of the temperament
that I bring to the process."
So I think that, among
the many lists of skills
that I think great law
students and lawyers have,
having that sense of
self-confidence on the one hand,
but a lack of hubris is a
big part of that temperament.
- One of the things that I
want to talk to you about
is being dean and the transformations that
are occurring in the legal profession
and in law schools.
But, before we get to that,
I want to ask something
about being a lawyer
as a cultural icon in the era
when you did your training.
And, by that, I mean that,
on the one hand, the Perry Mason,
the Clarence Darrow, the Louis Brandeis,
the Felix Frankfurter were seen as
people who one could
emulate to the extent that
you actually wanted to be them
or be one of the cohort
that they were part of.
So that's one thing.
The other thing a lawyer...
And this was less known.
Was, in training to go to law school,
you were becoming part of a guild.
Almost a medieval guild,
in the sense that you were
trained to learn a craft
and the guild limited the number of people
who were in the guild.
And then, thirdly, law...
I'm not trying to make a speech here.
- No, this is very helpful.
- The law, as a career,
was a default choice for many students.
I don't know what I want to
do, so I'll become a lawyer.
So talk a little about
those three strands,
especially in your time
when you were in law school.
because that's changing.
- So, it's a wonderful way to capture it.
Let me touch on all three,
'cause I think all they all come together
and, indeed, it's a wonderful segue
to the challenges we're facing right now
in the practice and legal education.
So, as to the first, yes, we put,
as I came to the law school,
myself and my classmates,
lawyers on an enormous pedestal.
Now, quite frankly, some of that
might have to do with going to Harvard
where there's such
distinguished careers of these
extraordinary graduates whose busts you
saw as you came to school,
but it really captured, in the
faculty and the curriculum,
the sense that we were entering
into a noble profession
and that maybe we would
have, as part of our careers,
arguing before the Supreme Court.
Now, I will say that that
was an aspiration for
a number of my classmates.
Elena Kagan was a classmate of
mine and a number of others.
So, there was a sense that
we could really aspire to greatness.
But the bottom line is we
saw the legal profession
as an extraordinary and
enormously important calling
and also with a real
sense of responsibility.
Now, you mentioned the guild.
And that's also had and
has a powerful force
on how we think about
the legal profession.
And the contrast that
I would draw, if I may,
is between entering the
guild of being a lawyer
or entering the guild of being a doctor
versus entering into a profession,
say, as a businessperson or others
where you don't really need
a particular credential
in order to be part of that.
So, the notion behind entering this guild,
which is, of course, a
long-standing tradition,
is that you had to go to law school.
Not just be educated in the law.
You had to go to law school.
And law school had to look
like a particular thing.
Three year program with a set curriculum,
taking a bar examination
after you graduate.
All of that that led to
being part of a club,
you might say, guild.
And, while that was probably
becoming anachronistic,
even when I was in law school,
we didn't have that sense.
And our faculty at Harvard
really gave us a sense that
they were giving us the training
that enabled us to be part
of this extraordinary club.
Sort of secret knowledge or information.
The last point that you touched on,
which is sort of the default issue,
is a really powerful one, as well.
By contrast, to go into
medical school, for example,
where there's an enormous amount
of training and scaffolding that goes into
building your background
to go to medical school.
You can sort of fall into law school.
Take a law school admissions
test, do well in college.
And so, there was a sense that
among the tens of
thousands of law students
who were going to, at the time,
the 160 or so United States
law schools, only a handful...
Well, maybe more than a handful.
That not a majority were folks that
really aspired to go to law school
because they loved studying the law
or really aspired to become a lawyer
because they saw it is a great calling.
So, in some sense, it's
one of the deficits
of the fact that anyone
can go to law school.
Nearly anyone can go to law school.
In that there's not a
lot of background sorting
that really gives one a sense of
what kind of career or
study they're entering into.
- Before we talk about
the challenges of a dean,
let's talk about being a dean.
What are the skills and temperament that
you think need to be
present if one, as a lawyer,
is also going to be dean of a law school?
- Well, so, let me get at that answer by
beginning with what is, I think,
hopefully a short sentence
of what the job entails.
So, there's all these different parts.
You could answer that question
by aggregating all the things that I do
in the course of my day.
But the real summary is
you're really looking at
360 degrees of the
entirety of the law school
as an organization.
Very much unlike what you
do as a law professor,
as a law student, or really
any other constituency group.
I am responsible for the overall
management, organization,
and the leadership of a
medium-sized organization.
I don't do it alone and
Lord knows I call upon
an extraordinarily able administration.
All of that's true.
But I have to have and am responsible
for having the big picture.
So, to the skillset.
Certainly, some of the
obvious answers that question
is organizational skills,
a sense of some financial literacy,
since I'm, after all, managing
a fairly large budget.
All of those skills are important.
Being a people person,
if I can use that phrase,
in terms of interaction.
But I would dig just a little bit deeper
and say that one of the
one of the skill sets
that's absolutely important
is a sense of appreciation for
the diversity and the breadth
of what we do in our particular schools.
You have to be or you
ought to be as a dean
to have not only a knowledge
of, but an appreciation for,
the work of the faculty.
The way in which faculty members balance
teaching and research,
for the aspirations and
objectives and goals
of your law students
and understanding what
they're going through.
You certainly have to have
an appreciation for the
diversity and breadth
of experience of your alumni.
Not only because you're
often in a position
of asking them for financial donations,
which we are, but also you're
really trying to capture
what their experiences
were in your law school.
Whether they graduated one
year ago or fifty years ago.
And that requires, I think,
the kind of breadth of experience that,
quite frankly, you don't
pick up in law school
or even as a tenured member
of a law school faculty.
- Where did your organizational
background come from?
Was this something you picked up
in the course of your education
or is it something that comes naturally?
- Well, it certainly
doesn't come naturally.
In all candor, I picked up...
Whatever skills I developed
in terms of organizational ability,
I began developing after
I was named as dean,
which is certainly not optimal.
You have to understand that I became dean.
Entered, in many respects,
the second part of my career
as an academic administrator
when I was 34 years old.
When I'd been on the faculty
here at Berkeley for 10 years
without any particular knowable skillset
that would have trained me to
be an academic administrator.
I'd never been an associate
dean, for example.
I'm not trying to be excessively humble
saying I didn't have skills.
But I didn't know whether I would have
the kind of skillset that would enable me
to lead a law school until I began
as dean at the University of San Diego.
- So, in a way, as dean...
You mentioned some of the
constituencies that you have.
So the political management
of those constituencies.
And I don't use political...
I use it in a positive sense,
not in a pejorative sense.
In addition, I guess, other
elements of the constituency
are law firms, state government,
and the Bar Association.
The managers of the...
- Not to mention your university setting.
Because as one dean,
maybe of a law school,
maybe someone else, put it,
we're a number of things simultaneously.
And one is we're middle level managers.
We're not the provost
and we're not the
chancellor or the president.
That's not to say that we don't have
an extraordinary realm of influence
or even power over our institutions.
But we also have to navigate,
to come back to a
federalism theme, if I may,
vertical relationships,
in addition to horizontal relationships.
- So in these times, there
are numerous challenges
that law schools are facing.
So, managing the transition
in a time of great change
is important additional component
of one's leadership as a dean.
Let's talk about these
various constituencies and
how they're changing in
what their expectations are of law school.
In one of your blog posts,
you mentioned the problems
being posed by state government,
in a way, in terms of,
at a time when you're trying
to rethink the curriculum,
states of New York and
California are saying,
"Well you should do this
or you should do..."
Talk a little about that,
because that's an important challenge.
- I'm glad you raised it.
It's very much on my mind.
And, indeed, it's on the mind
of a number of law
school deans and leaders.
There's a real paradox going on
or a real puzzle, you might say.
And I think you described it well.
On the one hand, this is a period of time
in which law schools are going
through an enormous amount
of innovation or needing to go
through a lot of innovation.
They're innovating in
terms of the curriculum,
at developing new modalities
of legal education,
new techniques of legal education.
Not unlike other parts of the university.
The role of technology and how we teach.
The significant role of
experiential learning
to try to sort of navigate
the twin challenges
of developing more
interdisciplinary education,
which is vitally important
to the practice of law,
on the one hand, but, on the other,
developing the kind of skillset that
enables our students to
become practice proficient
when the time they graduate.
And any number of other innovations.
So, there's a lot...
Suffice to say, there's a lot going on.
But, in order to...
And, at the same time, and
this is a very important point,
at the same time,
the costs of legal education
have become astronomical.
So all of us in American law schools,
even those of us who have the privilege
to lead elite American law schools,
have to be conscious of the high costs.
So the challenges are very acute.
And a number of law schools,
indeed, I think the
majority of law schools,
are rising to that challenge
and are developing quite
a lot of innovations.
Now, at the same time, one
of our constituency groups...
Very important that you mentioned.
Which is the State Bar
Associations and state government
have in mind what, from my perspective
and I think from many perspectives,
are truncated and, in many respects,
fairly narrow view of the obligations
and the responsibilities of a law school.
And one of the ways in
which they're manifest,
as I've written about and spoken about,
is the development of
additional core curriculum
that they are looking to insist upon
at law schools within their states.
Now, let's be clear.
They have the right to do that.
This is not an issue of prerogative
or freedom of law schools
to do whatever they do.
Our law schools are accredited
by the American Bar Association.
The students have a law degree,
can sit for the State Bar.
So, it's within the prerogative
of the state judiciaries
or the State Bar Associations
to not only cajole law schools,
but to even impose requirements.
The problem, though, is the imposition of
these very specific,
practice-oriented legal requirements
impose significant costs
and burdens on law schools.
Again, at a time in which law schools
are needing to economize.
And they also are trying to develop
and aspire to develop a
one-size-fits-all paradigm
on law schools, frustratingly,
just at the time that law
schools are innovating
in important ways to catch up to
the realities of legal practice.
So, these dilemmas collide
and create an enormous amount
of burdens on law schools.
And no one should weep about
the dilemma of law school deans.
The burdens that they
impose on law schools
are, of course, burdens
they impose on law students
and the ability of law schools
to really educate law students
for a very dynamic new economy.
- Does this become a problem
of political education,
in a sense?
In other words, the ability to communicate
with these various constituencies and say,
"Hey, I hear what you're asking for,
but, you know, we've got other pressures.
And you need to take that into..."
- You know, it's a great point.
And I would even broaden
the point to say this.
To bring it back to us.
Because what I've just
said sort of seems to
put the blame, as it were,
on these other constituency groups.
But let's face the law
school's responsibility.
We have conducted ourselves,
in American legal education,
for decades now, with a
sense of leave us alone.
We know what's best.
We'll develop our curriculum.
We'll hire a faculty.
We'll develop our mission.
And you guys just sort
of stay out of things.
And so, I mean, once the law schools
are accredited by the
American Bar Association,
which is not that burdensome of a process,
we've mostly lived in our ivory towers.
So, one of the fundamental
problems with that
is we have not done a very good job
over the course of the last many years
in communicating to
these constituency groups
why we're innovating, what
we're doing to innovate,
and what our missions are.
So, we're now in a very
difficult political position.
You mentioned political.
I think it's the right way to put it.
Where we're sort of
scrambling to articulate
a vision of what law
schools are looking to do
when it might be, if not too late,
then sort of in the fourth quarter,
if I could use a football
analogy, of this debate.
Then, we're in a position, again...
And I think political is the
right way to describe it.
Of seeming defensive,
seeming antagonistic,
and seeming condescending
to a number of well-meaning
lawyers and judges
who have been working
to engage in a dialogue
with law schools for a great many years.
So, I would just say that we
need to engage in a dialogue.
Not push back in the
sense of basically saying,
"Leave us alone to do
what we've been doing
for a number of decades."
But engage in a certain mea culpa
at the level of dialogue and
engage these stakeholders
in a very important conversation about,
frankly, what the future
of legal education
is going to be like in the coming years.
- In 2012, I guess the
ABA, the Bar Association,
did a report on law schools.
I was reading an account of
that and of their conclusions.
And one struck me, which was,
well, you might think about
not having tenure in law schools.
Now, that strikes me as one
of those recommendations that,
really, in the context of a
university and its governance,
is not very practical.
- Right, well, there's two ways to...
One doesn't want to
overread that sentence,
which comes in the context of,
as you know if you read it,
an omnibus report that
sort of throws out a number of ideas.
There was another part
of that report that says
law professors shouldn't think
that much about prestige.
There's another.
Law school should innovate more.
So, one way to understand
that is a little bit of...
I mean, it's kind of a bomb
throwing line, you might say.
But a bit of a maybe you
should think about that.
The other way to think about it, though,
is in a moral alarmist sense,
which is what they're really
urging upon law schools.
The vast majority of which
are part of universities.
Is really to abandon this
extraordinary device that,
of course, has been part of universities,
if not forever, then
for quite a bit of time.
That, of course, that reading presents an
enormous amount of controversy.
I will just say this on the larger issue.
There's two very different
dimensions of this debate
about job security and
tenure for law professors.
One dimension that you just touched on
is whether it's a good
idea for law schools
to have essentially tenure
or tenure-like protections
for their full-time faculty.
That's a larger topic, I'll just say.
As a sentence, I think it is a good idea
and I think law schools have developed,
as part of universities,
extraordinary abilities.
In no small part because of
having a full-time faculty
that's doing teaching and research.
But I'll say the other dimension of that
is a very different one.
And that is not so much a
counseling to law schools
to give up on tenure,
but actually an exhortation to the ABA
in accrediting law schools,
the American Bar Association,
not to require tenure.
And that's more of an
argument about innovation.
Let a thousand flowers bloom.
That is, let law schools experiment
with different modalities of organization.
And, if a law school wants to develop
a paradigm of different
kinds of teaching...
Maybe relying upon practicing
lawyers or adjunct faculty
or maybe having term contracts
or other sorts of devices.
Maybe that would be a
good thing to try out.
I'm much more sympathetic, I should say,
to that paradigm, because
that really gives us a sense
of the marketplace of ideas
and marketplace of innovation,
which I'm quite sympathetic to.
- So, it becomes important
for all the players to,
on the one hand,
understand the problems of
particular constituencies,
but, on the other hand,
be open to innovation
wherever it's coming from.
One of the other challenges...
I mentioned law firms.
There seems to be quite
an amazing transformation
occurring within firms,
their hiring practices, the
whole nature of partnership,
and the building of an
entrenched hierarchy within firms
where the people at the very top
who've been in the firm a long
time are doing quite well,
but this may not be true
of the younger lawyers.
- That's exactly right.
There's extraordinary changes.
A wide amount of changes going on
in our great American law firms.
And, as in so many respects,
law schools are just
catching up to those changes.
And, you know, without
providing a bullet point list,
the role of technology, it
has transformed law schools.
Sorry, law firms in important ways
and reduced the need for
the kind of labor force
that was so characteristic
of these law firms
in the old firm where you'd have
a pyramid of law firm partners at the top
and this large army of associates
doing this extraordinary amount of work.
Clients are pushing back against law firms
assigning first or second year associates
who might bill at $500 or more an hour
to work on their particular cases.
So, as a consequence, law firms are hiring
fewer law firm associates.
There are issues of work-life balance
where a number of
lawyers, male and female,
are asking themselves, "Now, explain to me
why I'm spending 10 years
at the prime of my life
working like a dog with
a fairly remote chance
of being a partner."
Globalization has had enormous impact.
So these and other challenges are changing
the structure of American law firms
in very significant ways.
One of the most profound impacts
on law schools and legal education
is, quite simply, fewer
positions as law firm associates
and thus fewer positions
with significant remuneration
for law students who are
coming out of law school
with extraordinary amount of debt.
The larger question of
whether those law firms
will be permanently transformed
and the whole business model
of the large American or
worldwide law firm will change,
too soon to tell.
But I think the direction
is very much toward
fundamental structural
rather than cyclical change
in terms of the practice of law.
- So, does this mean that, you as a dean,
that you tinker with the curriculum,
but not make any drastic change
until you are sure that
the environment out there
has really changed?
- Well, you know, as a pundit once said,
a politician, I think,
"Where you stand depends
on where you sit."
And that's true of American law school.
So I think the challenge...
There are about 200 ABA
accredited law schools
and there's, of course,
quite a pecking order
in American law schools.
Only a fraction of those 200 law schools
send a significant critical
mass of their students
to the largest law firms
in the United States.
It doesn't mean that the other law schools
should go out of business.
Far from it.
It just means the vast majority
of American law schools
produce graduates who
go to smaller law firms.
Maybe solo practitioners.
Go into the public sector.
So, part of the challenge is
whether you tinker with the curriculum,
whether you develop different
modalities of instruction
depends on where you are in that ambit.
So, to bring it back to my law school
or this law school here at
Berkeley, which I was a part,
where we do send so many of our
students to large law firms,
yes, we tinker or even make
more substantial changes
to our law school curriculum.
If I had to say what the
major innovation that
the nation's great law schools
are doing, including mine,
it's developing more
interdisciplinary training
and multidisciplinary training.
And what does that mean in practice?
It means developing the kinds
of skills in our students
so they can they can pivot
and be flexible in terms of
developing their skillset
and their careers.
So, yes, all the traditional
body of knowledge,
the kind of information they need
to be practicing lawyers from day one.
Yes, but also the development
of business skills,
the development exposure to technology,
the ability to read a spreadsheet,
to know something about coding,
to know something about
international initiatives.
There's just different kinds of skills
than the kinds of skills
that my law school,
when I went to law school,
really thought that
it was responsible for in
training its law students.
- So, a law student might
have to be thinking about,
"Well, I'm not going to be in a law firm.
I may actually be in a startup
or a number of startups.
Advising them about patent infringement
or, you know, the legality..."
Well, think of Uber and
Lyft that essentially...
Well, what are the local
rules that apply to taxi cabs
that we're gonna have
to become involved in?
- Well, that's exactly right.
And it's even more daunting than that,
because what a law student
now has to think of is,
"I may be entering a profession in which
I need to know now
that I'm developing the kind of skills
to enter into an economy that will
change rapidly over the course
of my first 10 or 20 years
of the profession in ways that
I can't expect or predict."
Technology will change in important ways
that will change the
nature of the practice.
The economic model of
legal practice will change.
I may not even be a
so-called practicing lawyer
10 years from now.
I may be a C-suite executive or
I may be an entrepreneur
or I might be working
in a university setting.
So, there's always been
uncertainty, right?
No one can predict their entire careers
when they look at it ex-ante.
But the kind of uncertainty and turbulence
that's happening in the profession now
is so striking that it
requires an enormous amount
of self-confidence and also
sort of risk-taking behavior
on the part of law students now
to know what they need to
develop the skills that
will enable them to
thrive in the new economy.
- When one thinks of
university curriculums,
they're often unwilling to accept change.
Faculty and sometimes the administrators
who are responding to the faculty.
Does that pose a particular
dilemma for deans?
- It poses a dilemma on steroids
and what I mean by that is
all of what you note about
maybe the innate conservatism
of university culture
is a dilemma that we
face in our law schools.
Added to that is the innate
conservatism of legal practice,
to go back to the guild
that you mentioned before.
You know, nothing succeeds like success
or if it ain't broke don't fix it.
And the basic idea being that law school
has succeeded as a profession
and the law school curriculum
has looked mostly like it
has for 100 years or more.
So, you contrast it with my colleagues
in the business school.
Whatever one might say
about business schools...
And I don't want to sit here
and valorize business
school education in America,
but the genius of business
schools in the last 50, 60 years
is they developed a market
for a Master of Business
Administration, an MBA,
that is not required by
any guild or any state.
You don't need an MBA to do anything.
So, what business goals...
And, if I sound jealous,
it's because I am a little bit jealous.
The business schools
have been able to develop
is innovation that
comes from the fact that
they are developing a body
of curriculum and training
that is, almost by design, keeps up with
trends and developments
in the modern marketplace.
Law schools could use some of that
in more modesty, more
humility, and more innovation
in how they develop their curriculum.
So, I think getting out of the
mindset that basically says,
"You know, what's good for law students
in the two thousand teens
is basically what was
good for law students in the 1940s" would
be a big part of the
progress that we could make.
- Another important
constituency is student alumni
and divide the Alumni category
into recent alumni and older alumni.
And I do that because the challenges
of recent alumni are much greater
than you've ever seen before.
And we should talk a little about that,
because tuition is going up,
students leave with a lot of debt,
if they're not on on scholarship,
and then they're not finding the job.
So, for recent alumni,
they're in a real bind.
- Oh, there's no question.
So, just focusing on the recent alumni.
It's a tale of two groups,
to oversimplify a bit.
One group are the group of
students and recent alumni
who you described who
come out, in some cases,
with crushing debt, substantial debt.
100,000, 200,000 is not that unusual.
And they come out with...
While they don't necessarily have regrets
about their legal education,
they come out often with
a fair amount of cynicism
and indeed stress that
comes from the fact that
their career choices
are, in important ways,
distorted by the fact
that they're gonna spend
a good number of years
early in their careers
paying off their student debt.
So, it doesn't mean that
they're hostile by any means.
Indeed, I spend a lot of time
working with their alumni.
But it's really a challenge keeping them
engaged with the law school
given the challenges they're
facing in the profession.
That's not to mention social
media and all of these issues
that have spent now a number of years...
Folks have spent a number of years
ganging up on law schools.
I said it's a tale of two alumni.
Another group of recent alumni
see the value of innovation
and greatly appreciate what law schools,
not only our law school,
but many law schools,
are doing to change the
playbook, to change the script.
And they are greatly
appreciative of the law schools
acknowledging that we have
spent all of these years
raising tuition,
all of these years with
existing business models,
but are looking to those
alumni to make challenges.
And I'll say the reason why
they're particularly appreciative of that
is they're in the real world.
They see the kinds of
changes that I'm describing.
They see the need for developing
different multidisciplinary
kinds of skills.
They see the need to develop
so-called soft skills,
leadership skills and the like
and I find them enormously important,
this group of recent alumni,
in terms of helping us
engage our constituency group
of students and faculty to the changes
that are taking place in the marketplace.
- Do you, in a way, almost
have to offer courses that
expose your students to
the changes in the world?
You mentioned globalization.
You mentioned the way technology
is transforming the economy.
Or are these courses that
should be offered in the law school
or should you send your students
to other courses on
whatever campus you're on
to learn about that,
because you can't give
them a map for their future
but you can give them tools
to think about mapping their future?
- I think it's a three pronged strategy.
And some some might add prongs to that.
One is certainly working
with folks across campus.
One of the great...
We talked about the innate
conservatism of universities.
The other side of that coin
is the enormous robust opportunities
presented by being part of
a major research university.
So, we at Northwestern have,
as the students here at Berkeley have,
opportunities to work across
campus with our colleagues
in the business school.
In our case of our law school,
we're right next door
to the medical school.
We work closely with
the engineering school
and other departments to
really develop a set of skills.
We started the first
three year JD-MBA program
about a dozen years ago
and we have now dozens and dozens
of graduates of that program
who go on into law and business
with those sorts of skills.
So the one prong is really developing
these cross-campus
initiatives and alliances.
The second is, you mentioned,
is courses within the law school.
That, in some sense, is the new frontier,
which is developing alongside
what I'll call the traditional
law school curriculum,
an enormous amount of skills.
So I have some rather
off-the-wall ideas in that regard.
I think our law students, for example,
should have exposure to coding.
They're not going to
all be out go out there
and do computer coding,
but, just as law students
and undergraduates
are expected to learn another language
during their time of their
undergraduate experience,
it wouldn't hurt our students.
It would only help them to have
some exposure to technology.
Some exposure to quantitative methods.
So, yes, we need to bring those
courses into the curriculum.
Just as an aside, let me
say the challenge there
is not so much student receptivity,
but faculty bandwidth and
that is to bring in courses
over to the law school,
it means to bring in a faculty
that can actually train them.
I'll say, third and very briefly,
the third prong is lifelong
education and learning.
The notion that, in these
precious three years,
we can do all that's necessary
to train law students
to be able to aspire to leadership
in the new economy is naive.
So, we need to engage our alumni,
recent alumni and not so recent alumni,
to really provide the kind
of training and education
that begins in earnest once
they graduate from law school.
So, we're not just
sending off our students
into the brave new world,
but we're engaging with alumni
in terms of lifelong training.
So, such programs...
We have a corporate counsel institute
that helps young graduates
who are working in the corporate sector.
There are many examples,
but I think that's very important.
- Is this an argument for
reducing the number of years in law school
and taking the third year
and sending them out into the world
or at least making the
third year more of a year
in which you go out,
the student goes out, into the world
and works in a startup,
whatever, in a hospital
to see what the issues are
in medical delivery services and so on?
- I'm smiling, because, of course,
you put your finger on what's
an enormous, vigorous debate right now
that's in the media and
certainly within law schools
about the famous question
of whether the third year
is or is not expendable.
And there're very
different points of view.
And I would summarize my
own thinking about that
by saying this.
I don't think the third year
in law school is expendable
in the sense that what
we're basically doing
is either giving them a
taste of practical training
that they would be better suited to do
if they were actually
out into the practice
nor do I think that
having advanced subjects,
what we used to call the law and subjects,
law and philosophy, law and
economics, law and business,
is just window dressing.
We only have them for three years.
And the first year is really
a sort of foundational year.
So, I think, at best,
the third year can build the bridges
between doing substantial academic work.
Let's face it, this is probably
their last year of higher education.
But also significant practical work.
It's, quite frankly, I think,
rather naive and misleading
to expect that the third year,
if replaced from law school,
could just be handed over to
large law firms or to
judges or to startups
to develop the kinds of
skills that students need.
The economic model doesn't
really sustain that.
The challenge, though, to
come back to the challenge,
is whether the third year
is justified by its cost,
because some of the attention,
and President Obama referred to this,
I think, about a year and a half ago,
some of the tension about
this third year of law school
comes from the fact that students
are already facing an
enormous amount of debt.
They might have the skills to take
and pass a bar examination
after two years.
So, what's the justification
to pay another $50,000
and another year out of the work force
in order to take all these
wonderful classes in law school?
- What happens to
affirmative action efforts
in the context of these great
transitions that are going on?
- That's a great question.
I think that the larger question of
how we continue to commit to diversity
in our law schools in the
face of these challenges
is a very, very hard issue.
I don't mean it's hard in terms of
where our commitment should lie.
I mean it's hard at the
level of implementation.
So, in the era that we're in now
where all the challenges
that we've been talking about
are being faced and, in
addition to all of that,
there's this overlay of almost paranoia
about rankings of law school,
about making sure we can sort
of elbow our way to the top,
with all of those issues
that are being faced,
and included in that the decline
of law school applications,
diversity and affirmative
action can often be
left by the side of the road
and that it can become,
as with law firm hiring,
an expendable objective and goal.
Now, I don't think that that's warranted,
but I think that we need
to redouble our efforts
to make sure that we are not
cutting off our nose to spite our face.
- I have one question I want to ask you
about being president of the Association.
What sort of things did
you learn in that position
as you looked at other law schools,
that hadn't come to your attention
in being the leader of
Northwestern's law school?
- You know, it's a wonderful question.
Although there were days when I wondered,
"Now, why exactly did I
undertake this particular hobby,
as it were?"
More are the days I really felt like
I learned an enormous amount
and hopefully contributed a bit.
One of the things I learned is just
the enormous diversity of missions
of so many of our American
law schools and of strategies.
I had a sense of what was going on
in a number of law schools
or thought I knew a great amount.
I had been at a number of law schools.
I had led two.
But it was really only when I was visiting
with so many law schools
and working with the faculty
and the deans and undertaking
this leadership role
that I really had a sense
of the challenges faced by
the wide range and scope of
public and private law schools.
Some that are freestanding.
Many that are in states that face
enormous economic challenges.
Much worse than places like
California and Illinois and Texas.
So, it gave me a sense of appreciation
for how schools were facing
these particular challenges.
It also gave me a sense of the diversity
of faculties of these
particular institutions
of which we were a part.
So, I had spent quite a lot
of time learning a lot more
about the changing role of
what I'll say the legal
professoriate is like.
- So I guess my final question is
will the image of the
lawyer remain the same,
the positive image?
There's also a negative image,
but let's talk about the positive image.
In an address, I guess,
to a graduating class,
you summed up nicely.
You said that is the ideal of the lawyer.
You said and where there
are small issues at stake...
That is, you're talking about
the mission of the lawyer.
And you said "Where there
are small issues at stake,
wrongdoing in government,
suffering of individuals
who require justice,
problem solving in the
corporate boardroom,
new exciting startup
businesses to be formed,
liberties to be protected,
and rights to be enforced,
we find that lawyers are there
and they are at the ready
to deploy their skills,
to render their advice,
to analyze and advocate,
to be the engineers of justice,
the protectors of the rule of law."
Will that...
It's a nice statement of the ideal.
- A little long.
I wish I had actually
broken into maybe three sentences.
- Maybe I didn't read it well,
but, the point is, do you
think that view of the law
and the lawyer will endure?
- I'm cautiously optimistic.
Here's what I would say about that.
Certainly, in the
context of those remarks,
I was speaking to a graduating
class of law students.
All of whom I want them to feel that
they're entering into a
great and noble profession
and not have a sense to
come back to something that
you asked about at the beginning
that law is just a default.
That it's not only an important career,
but a noble career.
Having said that, my answer
to whether or not that is
still a worthwhile
description or depiction
of the role of the lawyer is contingent.
That is I believe it ought to be the case
and I'm cautiously optimistic that it
will be the case on the
following condition.
Is that, as we adapt...
We, in legal education
and in the profession,
adapt to the changes that we're facing.
Complacency is no longer justified.
The ordinary business model
of law schools and law firms
are no longer justified.
Our ability to remain
in our rightful place,
by which I don't mean our god-given place,
I mean our rightful place as the guarantor
of individual liberty,
as the protector of the wise
constraints that make men free
and all of that will very much
be dependent on our ability
to navigate some real challenges,
to work with other professions,
and to provide the kinds of
skills and training and education that
will enable young lawyers, in particular,
to be able to adapt to this
tsunami of changes that
are facing not only the legal
profession, but the economy.
And, if we can do that, I'm quite bullish,
as the saying goes, on the
ability of legal education
to continue to work for another 100 years
as it has for the past 100 years
as, really, an ennobling
educational endeavor for folks
in this new world.
- Well, on that positive note,
Dean Rodriguez, I want
to thank you very much
for taking the time to be on our program.
- My pleasure.
- And thank you very much for joining us
for this Conversation with History.
(soft music)